they're like you kidnapped your daughter
what yeah he's they're like we're gonna
kill her unless you pay this much she's
right next to him well she wasn't home
at the time but my dad's like killer
[Music]
so uh there's a tenant right and he
lives in this a uh in a house that he's
renting oh very normal he's a renter
Colleen's not buying it she's not buying
it dude she's like that don't happen
right yeah I'm waiting for more
information
of course I'm not gonna Ryan us you know
what I mean
guess the article can you guess the
punchline like what happens right after
this guy who pays rent
what the heck what happens huh tenant in
the house he farted and uh he's playing
red
that's good why is that so funny too he
farted that's it that's the article and
it's like there's a lot of [__]
about whatever but that's the yeah so
this is the part here's the part where
you guys
tune in next week to kids news
all the latest fart news so
um this guy is paying rent in this house
uh uh got that already thank you
jackass wait what'd you do you spoiled
it you know I just said we all right we
got the fact that he's paying the Last
Two Dollars let me convert this it's
called it costs just under half a
million dollars this house and then he
tries to sell it well he's just renting
it
without the landlord
this guy is [__] sick bags hate him
this is genius Banks hate him real
estate agents he's undercutting
everybody over this one simple trick wow
sign up for a master of my course if you
want to figure out how to do it so it
wasn't fart but yeah that was that's
that's it you're gonna guess that that's
what they mean by rent to own
and then he reads the title he's like
okay now you guys uh
he just like let's let's lose the all
right the Bull's out of the gate you're
making it funny do your stupid thing oh
man so he so he reads his place and then
just two weeks after he's given the keys
he lists the place uh to sell it
um and now he's been his name is Andrew
Smith he's age 41. so he's new here to
Earth he's a foreigner yeah he's new
here he's just trying to work the system
I kind of I got to give him props yeah
this is not in the U.S no no he's in the
UK he's been jailed for two and a half
years for this crime now oh my god oh
wow let him free dude let him free did
he start trying to sell the jail
well maybe he was like instead of doing
a sublease I'm gonna do a sub own oh
that's nice you got a piece of pie you
know that you don't own it's not man it
works yeah so yeah he's been jail for
two and a half years the police are
calling this one quote unquote truly
Brazen
um he was originally moving to Cambridge
for work uh two weeks later he listed
the property for sale by a fake estate
agent the fraudulent sale went as far as
one potential buyer agreeing a price and
even visiting the property with a
drainage surveyor oh my God however it
soon became clear that uh that wasn't
the case he didn't own the [__] he
didn't have the papers
um there he was uh he basically let me
see I didn't dummy some papers what an
idiot didn't really think too far the
buyer later spoke to the actual agent of
the spot was which is what happened and
then ended up talking to the police
because uh it revealed that the
documents provided were by Smith were in
fact fraudulent and it was not his house
so he did have fraudulent papers but
they just didn't work out but yeah this
is his mug shot I think it's important
to always put a face to the crime just
in case what do you guys think he looks
like scale one to ten ten being hot as
[__] go ahead clean so hot 10 you're
already tending this guy no maybe you
don't love it no way potentially at 11.
no way in hell potentially 11 dick
that's what she said I did not say he's
like a five five or six how would you
actually rate this guy
there's like all three of the guys and
Friends combined yeah it looks like a
mashup it does look like that whoa It's
a perfect mix I'd like to speak for
women yeah it's a lot of swimmer in
there
if you if he was successful at this
crime it would make him hotter but if he
because he's unsuccessful with a [__]
mug shot it made him uglier how about
that yeah you stole my thoughts it's
like the founder of a European Bank yeah
there he is there's the founder of
European Bank yeah it's ex-soviet
Central isn't that such a classic crime
though like the selling of something you
don't own that's like one of the oldest
like things the bridge yeah the bridge
thing yeah is that called theft what's
the bridge thing uh was it Brooklyn
Bridge oh yeah somebody tried to like
they were like selling and then someone
they succeeded yeah yeah wait someone
sold the Brooklyn Bridge yeah they
literally just went hey you want to buy
this bridge and then the rich guy was
like is it a bridge there's like wait
this bridge is on sale
because I can put a toll here Black
Friday
yeah when did that happen a long time
like a historical like dumbass crime
it's like one of those like old ones
it's like funny now I think it was like
you gotta act now 18th uh wait George C
Parker I'm trying to move this bridge
quick got a lot of buyers a lot of
buyers it didn't say exactly one but he
was born in 1860 1936 uh an American
common best known for his repeated
successes selling the Brooklyn Bridge I
guess he did it multiple times
did you sell the whole thing this is
like what you want to be known for like
something like this like a real Caper
that you keep on doing and proving how
stupid everyone around you is is pretty
good that's pretty cool there you know
what's another common thing is is a lot
of people lease spaces not knowing
they're leasing from the person leasing
it like a sublease yeah right but they
they're not aware of that they think
that's the owner that happened to a lot
of dance studios they like they thought
they were oh I know what you're talking
about yeah they thought it was directly
the uh person it was like a pyramid scam
of dance studio leases I guess it was
like several degrees from the actual
owner wow is it easier to trick dancers
yes okay yeah yeah all right I can't
speak for dancers there's a lot of them
though there is a lot of them I think
when it comes to The Starving Artists
that's pretty easy to trick any of them
yeah that's true this guy's [__]
funny I'm a Brooklyn Bridge guy Brooklyn
Bridge guy was selling the uh Brooklyn
Bridge so that uh he would basically
convince people are buying that they
would have controlling access to the
bridge so these people would start
putting up [__] toll booths but the
police kept on removing
that guy's the ultimate toll
oh good talk Anthony love that one I did
Anthony that's nice isn't it very if he
really likes a pun he go
es
[Laughter]
yeah because it's so good it's good it's
tight yeah I already know what he likes
bro yeah
to me I was okay with theft and burglary
and assault and maybe armed robbery and
maybe home invasion yeah when it came to
con and scams I felt really bad like I
thought that those were the worst crimes
possible and I do think that there are
honorable criminals out there that will
rob you in your face at that point at
gunpoint and I think that's way more of
a stand-up crime because you know what
you're getting versus someone who's like
trying to con you out of your money you
don't think chicken rich guy that you
that he owns the Brooklyn Bridge now and
every time he tries to put up a tall
Booth the police take it away and he's
like you guys better stop [__] with
my papa damn
that's [__] as funny as a kid
he's saying it's honorable though you
know what I mean I'm thinking about the
[__] faces that go out and con grandmas
and stuff you know oh yeah that's not
fun like they're like hey Social
Security calling you [__] messed up
yeah
it's not even funny yeah yeah Insurance
scams all that stuff there's um one of
my um favorite things to do is watch
hackers basically infiltrate all of
these scammers and they they find all
the like poor old ladies that they can't
and then they find the old ladies and
then they pay them back and then they
get these like like scam call centers
they're really dope is there a way to
stop those scammers what is there a way
to stop those scammers like the people
that like there's just they're
untraceable right no yeah there's so
many of them they haven't figured it out
yet they just pop up again after they
get taken yeah it's hard there's too
many because they're like in like a
little Bungalow or apartment or
somewhere and then once they get like
[__] found out everybody [__] tear
everything down and then they just go to
the next spot it's just like um it's
like those uh smog shops the hood yeah
you ever seen those when they get caught
so like the Star smog stations where
they smog cars they you just basically
pay them off to smog your [__]
polluting car and then as soon as they
get caught they all rotate they rotate
ownership they'll be like five shots UPS
all in the same guy so they go okay
sorry and they'll go and they'd like a
clock like a like a Catholic priest yep
yeah that's how they do it shuffle them
wow Shuffle it back into the deck yep
yikes scams and cons baby you know I got
a I got a DMV uh letter this morning
about renewing my registration and said
I had to get a small check and the first
thing I thought to my mind was like I
gotta hit up Ryan
I don't know this is legit you know what
I mean you know another con that they do
is as soon as you open up a yell page
they call the number and they say oh you
haven't been paying your electric bill
you're if you don't pay it now we're
gonna shut it down in like 20 minutes
dude I get that call all the time bro I
get texts like that yeah and I'll be
like okay shut it right and they just
hang up on you and then you go oh my God
my phone line
close your account I'm like yeah
I'm not a [__] old lady dude like
like yeah I'm like I'm so used to these
things is I'm just completely numb dude
I wish I was I wasn't that gullible
because even though I know it's [__]
I still look it up I still look it up
dude I'm never I'm never like will the
IRS call you and they're like they'll
never call you I'm like oh thank god
dude my dad got a call I was with my dad
and he got a call and he got one of
those like crazy ones where they're like
you kidnapped your daughter what yeah
they're like we're gonna kill her unless
you pay this much she's right next to
him well she wasn't home at the time but
my dad's like killer
and then he was like and he'll go up I
was like Dad what if it's true he goes
[Music]
then he just starts laughing again where
is she yeah like dude that's crazy I see
what Ryan got his Wild Side my humor
comes from him yeah did I tell you about
that government agent that called me up
for the yeah yeah that was the heaviest
one I've ever heard of wow so there's a
scam go going around for people that are
in crypto and it's been going around
actually in uh the last five plus years
it's not just crypto it's also stocks so
um one of my friends clients went
through the same exact thing
and they lost like two mil yeah so being
the scam in the scam but basically [__]
um so I think they the way that they
it's it's generally like this you can
see this on the IRS website as well as
the FBI website telling you do not call
back uh when the agencies call and say
like you know they represent IRS FBI all
this stuff uh and say like you need to
help with this investigation because the
scam runs like this like they find your
information for me I made a video on
Luna and said how much I lost whatever
they found my number online they left a
voicemail saying that they're from
Washington DC
um and they're a part of this government
agency they have a way to probably get
my money back
um they just need my cooperation and
this and that give them a call back and
I was like man this is kind of fishy
because one they didn't say my real full
name they said JoJo sukawa which is my
uncle Instagram Uncle chin hi can I talk
to Uncle Chen
also known as Joe Mama Joe's like this
is fishy I'll call back weird so there's
a government there's a government number
there's a government number like
everything whatever like it does say
Washington DC but that's easy to do
right like whatever
I didn't call back because I was like
what the [__] if it is real like I'm not
gonna cooperate like I'm down with dog
Quan dude like [__] it let's go let's go
you know are they like are they like I
just need you to answer these security
questions uh number one do you like to
jack off
now that's the kind of interview I'm
down to do right and then Joe's like yes
like okay
[Laughter]
and Luna and terraform Labs is under
investigation by us and we need your
help uh we want to know we want we're
building up a case whatever right and
then so I never called them back but the
the person that my friend hit one of his
clients that did get caught up what
ended up happening was they posed as if
they were the FBI said they're running
an investigation they need his help
uh it's got to stay secret because it's
they made him feel like he's this AJ
super agent so then this guy dude he's a
doctor like a dentist or something right
he's a doctor dentist so he's all like
oh [__] I'm working for the government
it's [__] top secret right and during
the whole process they milked them out
of like a lot how do they get access to
his money like as the government you
know we do need to have access to your
bank account
we can get you your money back we just
need your money it was like a several
year scam that they had to it started
with increments and I I don't know
exactly that part of it but by the time
he was telling me like how it got like
it was just like okay I was like I don't
want to deal with this like I'm not
gonna call him back so I didn't really
dig deep into it but that's the gist of
the con maybe it's like for every
thousand dollars you give our
investigation we'll give you two
thousand dollars back
and if you have any friends that wants
to be a part of this investigation you
could be like hey you want to make some
part-time money on uh full-time money on
a part-time basis you probably could
have really been like hey uh so I really
want to continue this case but they just
cut our Department's funding yeah yeah
it could be so we need yours we're so
close to getting this bastard
I do need I do need to know like are you
down to be a super agent but work from
home
aren't you tired of your job
that is oh that's a great incentive
ready to do your duty but the craziest
thing really was that the guy that was
leaving you messages he just sounded
like an actual like white dude yes it
wasn't like one of those guys trying to
sound white he sounded like a legit
white guy they got a real white so it's
like that automatic oh trust that dude
he's a government agent you know he's
like Mr Jones it's a goat he talked like
you talk to lingo yeah yeah Bureau lingo
Mr Uncle Chan
oh